we are of course not expecting any kind
of massive decrease in the rubles
exchange rate because the decline in the
oil price we saw was the third biggest
in the last 40 years and the amount of
external debt that has to be paid this
year is about a third less than last
year
year-on-year inflation could it go
beyond 20 percent
inflation may be higher than the current
15
we have inflation about 15 percent in
annual times now but these higher levels
of inflation are driven by past factors
moreover i'd like to point out that
other inflationary factors will subside
we expect a contraction in economic
activity and of course a contraction in
demand
on top of that we have very moderate
dynamics in the money supply data
that's why we really expect inflation to
slow down in the second quarter after
the second quarter in the second half of
the year and into 2016.
that's why there is no reason to talk
about the inevitability of a rate
increase
when do you see lowering rates
we'll make the decision on rates based
on our analysis of the situation in the
economy our forecasts on the economy's
development and above all on the
dynamics of inflation
analyzing the entire balance of risks
inflationary risk to growth and to
financial stability
we'll make a decision that is consistent
with our task of reducing inflation
within the framework of our inflation
targeting and achieving a level of four
percent in the mid term
when you lowered rates from 17 to 15 you
surprised almost everybody
and the conversation began how
independent really is russia's central
bank are you independent or is this an
arm of the kremlin
when we made the decision on cutting
rates we didn't do it at the expense of
inflation nor was water to the expense
of our task in reducing inflation
we based it on our forecast for
inflation and for economic growth
of course there is a lot of criticism of
the central bank but the bank of russia
is very used to criticism there are
interest groups in the economy some gain
from a weak ruble others gain from a
strong ruble
for many years the central bank has been
criticized on all sides so we are used
to it
are you independent
we are independent
where do you see growth in 2015 if the
oil price is around 50 bucks
yes
if oil is going to be around where it is
now around 50 dollars a barrel our
latest estimates show the economy will
decline
we'll have a contraction of about three
to four percent
how big of an issue are the sanctions
for you as you run the bank
sanctions are of course negative
we can see that in our balance of
payments and the pressure on the
exchange rate and inflationary effects
it's an issue but we are trying to react
to it with our own instruments we've
developed new methods new instruments to
help banks and companies pay their
external debt like foreign currency
refinancing we are becoming more
flexible in order to answer the
challenges
i guess as a central banker it makes you
work a little bit harder
it makes the the sanctions make your
life a bit more
challenging
naturally
how concerned are you
about a banking crisis in russia
we are constantly monitoring the banking
system
there is no doubt the economy's
contraction will affect the banking
system
but that's an absolutely expected event
bankers will offer less loans
lending rates will be a little bit
higher because there will be credit
creditors
and the quality assets will get worse
but we don't see any systemic problems
our stress tests show that the banking
sector will get through this difficult
period in a stable condition
you've obviously been studying
how other countries have gone through
similar crisis to the one that russia's
in now have you identified some things
that you say to yourself that's thing
that's one thing that this central bank
definitely won't do
it
what we won't do for sure we won't spur
economy growth by raising inflation
issuing more money in my view other
countries experience with that has been
absolutely obvious
countries attempt to spur economic
growth by increasing inflation by
excessively pumping money into the
system leads to the exact opposite
secondly we won't fix the exchange rate
and third we won't impose administrative
restrictions on capital flows
i think it's absolutely unproductive
what's your biggest fear
it's not even a fear it's a concern and
the task we need to take on for our
future we need structural reforms
because neither monetary no budget
policy can create stable economic growth
they're just conditions for growth in
order to create stable growth we need to
improve the investment climate we need
private investment measured budget and
monetary policy adjust conditions for
those reforms which could take the
country into entirely different growth
trajectory that's what worries me most
everyone always talks about conducting
structural reforms but they haven't
really happened
but now it's vital
you know the russian president you're
his economic advisor i'm sure you speak
on occasion now
do you think he's ready for structural
reforms
yes i'm absolutely sure of that
do you have a favorite central banker or
a central banker out there outside of
russia that you say wow i really respect
what they do
i've got a lot of respect for paul
walker he was able to reduce inflation
and carry the country through a
difficult period
how often do you check the oil price
just
often
several times a day really
why is the central bank buying so much
gold
we really did increase our gold
purchases in 2014.
we did it for two reasons first we are
diversifying our foreign currency and
gold reserves and two we are solving the
problem of ruble liquidity we have a
lack of collateral when the central bank
provides rubles to commercial banks a
lot of emerging countries have this
problem that's why we are developing
operations involving gold purchases in
order to provide ruble liquidity we've
got a pretty big share of gold in our
reserves a little less than 12 percent
but we are not the biggest cause holders
you've got 39 close to 39 million troy
ounces how much more gold do you need
we'll decide based on the situation what
are you going to do with it all
right that's what reserves are for
whether they're in gold or foreign
currency they may be needed in different
situations president putin met with the
leaders of germany and france over the
weekend peace talks for ukraine
you're sitting in the central bank
the ruble strengthened in the in the um
lead up to those talks there were
expectations
how do you prepare
for the reaction to them
a lot of factors affect the rebels
exchange rate geopolitics of course and
oil we've moved to a floating rate
we assume that under the influence of
various factors geopolitical the oil
price and the domestic economies
condition the ruble rate will be defined
by market factors
that's why we don't make any special
preparations for monitoring how these or
that factor will affect the ruble i
repeat we will only intervene in the
foreign currency market if there are
moves that create risks to financial
stability
there was a moment in december when the
ruble
fell to 80 to the dollar
could that happen again
december the 16th was a really
particular day in a lot of ways
there was a great deal of volatility and
a big jump in the exchange rate but why
was the day unique because that was the
day
that we de facto moved to a floating
ruble at the beginning of november we
announced that we'll shift to a floating
ruble but due to our assessments of the
risks to financial stability we
intervened on the foreign currency
market frequently and the market got
used to those interventions
but december 16th we left the market we
really left the market that was the
shift to a floating exchange rate
that's why we increased the key rate at
the same time and the volatility in a
lot of ways was driven by this shift
from one approach that we had for many
years when we control the exchange rate
manage the rate to a floating regime
that's one way of saying you don't see
the ruble returning to 80 to the dollar
i don't see any reason for such sharp
moves